welcome back while on Friday night the
former University's minister at Sanremo
became the latest member of the
government to quit and subsequent Relief
Act a second referendum which may be
music to the ears of our next guest the
campaigner Gina Miller thank you very
much for being on the show with us now
before we get to the talk part second
referendums I'm keen to get your
thoughts on the interview that we've
just heard and Nick Bowles he's
proposing Norway plus if you like
staying in the single market is that
something that you'd support I think
anything is better than actually this
withdrawal agreement we've got which is
just giving away sovereignty giving away
everything it is worse possible deal I
don't know how it took this long to get
here but the thing is it doesn't matter
if it's Norway plus a plan B the reality
of where we are is that any option will
require an extension to article 50 we
don't have the time because in Nick's
suggestion of Norway plus you'd have to
negotiate with the members of after
you'd have to go and look at the
protocols in the EA it's not just going
to something we can take off the shelf
and we don't have the practical time to
do that with the 29th of March looming
and I guess it's the same for labor
we've heard problems the case done
without talking about a general election
yeah I mean whatever the options are
right now the reality is what counts and
the reality is this vote is not going to
get through Parliament in nine days time
you know that the Prime Minister what is
Plan B is it at an election that she
calls herself is it an election that the
Labour Party wants to call a vote of
no-confidence is as an alternative is it
sending her back
whatever the alternatives are other than
No Deal would require an extension and
this idea that there is a no majority in
parliament for No Deal I must just point
out that if there is no other option
because of the MPS allowing article 50
to be triggered no deal is the legal end
game here so there this iso-ne will not
stop it so they can't stop it because
what they should have done is all these
wranglings and everything is going on
now when I won my case this is where
those debates should have been happening
because too many MPs because so many of
them triggered article 50 without really
thinking about the consequences of that
the actual legal end game of that
trigger is
No Deal if there's no other option and
I'm interested in your thoughts about a
second referendum there's been more and
more talk about the possibility of
having another Bret's that boat surely
that would be a gift to the far right I
don't think you would be and the reason
I say that is because you have to if you
just clear away the bluster and the
noise and this whole idea the will of
the people two years ago look at what
people are saying now and the poles plus
traveling around the country that I've
been doing for months and months and
months people are saying we actually do
want to say we do want to find out
what's going on we do want to now we
know more and this is not about leave or
remain or anything like that you know
it's 73 percent of the Labor Party
membership it's 112 labour constituency
it's a 67 Conservative Party it's a who
are on the sort of video the on the
border of their seats you know there's
so much here where people are saying we
want to have a say on this and decide
what happens in the future and the other
thing to point out in this is if we are
now pushing for a general election from
both parties that is a waste in my view
to go back to the people because an
election should be about your full
manifesto in your policies for all
sectors of society not to be just
dominated by one issue you're talking
about the conversations that you've been
having and around the country as you
know on the show we try and get out and
about as well and I have to say and I do
think there is a large number of people
in the UK who would feel utterly
betrayed if there was a second
referendum and the worst thing perhaps
is I don't think they would even feel
that surprised it's almost as if they
expect it to happen I think that's all
what's on the establishment - I think to
me the ride in my opinion that it
wouldn't be because it would be what's
on the ballot paper and whilst it's the
MPs and Parliament will have to decide
that the Electoral Commission if we got
to that stage which I think we will get
to and we're edging towards it as being
the only plausible way out of this mess
this political mess then I think
actually No Deal would have to be on the
ballot I think we would have to be fair
to everyone and so that's why I believe
it would have to be all three options
because we couldn't have a situation
where people felt that they voted leave
and they didn't actually they weren't
listened to we have to respect that vote
and
just finally and you successful business
within ya you've decided to come stick
your neck about the parapet if you like
on brexit and you get some pretty
vicious abuse on social media and
elsewhere I mean I've seen it announcing
that you were on the show does that for
me feel why do you go through all this
I've been a campaigner for nearly twenty
thirty years now and I've always felt
that people have the right to be spoken
to honestly and to be given an
information in a way they can understand
to make an informed choice and that's
what I'm campaigning for I think process
matters honesty to people matters and
people having the information you know
I've even gone to the extents of
launching a new campaign in September
which is sort called end the chaos
because I thought this is where we'd be
and our remit is to try and answer
people's questions they're not being
spoken to in a way that can give them an
informed choice and help them understand
where they are and surely that's what we
should all be doing and and I'm gonna
carry on fighting for that I'm going to
carry on fighting for people to have the
right to understand what's going on okay
Gina Miller thank you very much